certains diront que le mouvement
s'essouffle en terme de fréquentation du
continue en tout cas 14e samedi de
mobilisation contre le pass sanitaire
plusieurs rassemblements prévus à
travers toute la france à paris le
cortège organisé par florian philippot
s'élancera à 15 heures de la place du
trocadéro sont souvent un défilé pour la
liberté et les ville et jaune ont
régulièrement battu le pavé chaque
samedi pour dénoncer la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement et le fameux
pass mais aujourd'hui ils appellent à
une mobilisation générale et à une
reprise des recoupements dans tout le
pays pour dénoncer ce qui avait été le
fond le départ de leurs mouvements la
hausse des prix du carburant au trou
dans le cortège des gilet jaune notre
reporter nadège adhara sa
dette bonjour alors il y at il déjà du
monde
[Musique]
ils sont plus ou moins nombreux les chez
les jeunes ils sont plusieurs centaines
à rassembler pour l'instant autour de
cette place de la bastille en général
ils arrivent en plus grand nombre une
fois que le cortège démarre alors ce
qu'on peut vous dire à l'heure actuelle
c'est que l'objectif de segi les jeunes
présents et 6 et de raviver la flamme de
la colère sociale qui est bien est né en
novembre 2018 avec la création du
mouvement trois ans après la situation
est bien pire qu'à ce moment là et pour
cause il n'y a pas que le carburant qui
a augmenté aujourd'hui les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité
explosent également alors avec nous pour
en parler faouzi lellouche un qui est
l'une des figures de ce mouvement d
gilet jaune faouzi vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat partagé par de nombreux
gilet jaune ici la situation est pire
qu'au moment de la naissance du
mouvement d'exactement déjà bonjour à
tous et puis tout le monde dans son
quotidien est capable de voir et de
constater les augmentations continues
sur les produits de première nécessité
ce qu'on avait demandé dès le début on
peut voir que tout a augmenté
concernant les énergies tout augmente
alors bon vouloir donc il ya des vraies
excuses alors que pourtant pas remis
parmi ces prix par exemple je prends
l'exemple d'un litre de gasoil 80
centimes htva pour l'état dans les taxes
donc je pense qu'ils auraient pu réduire
aussi leurs bénéfices dessus parce que
ça devient du bénéfice à 80 centimes
quand on paye le prix d'un litre 1 euro
60 1 euros 50 donc j'estime que c'est
abusé de prendre les gens comme ça de
haut et de se dire que il ya des gens
qui sortent depuis trois ans et en fin
de compte on en a rien à faire on les
écoute pas et pire on les réprimandes
donc voilà il était important de revenir
comme d'arrêt comme on était là tous les
samedis mais avec une vraie visibilité
de dire que voilà les choses al peuvent
changer que par les citoyens parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un
un parti politique ou une opposition à
part les citoyens qui peut essayer de
nous permettre de bénéficier de ce qu'on
réclame c'est à dire pouvoir vivre
dignement simplement correctement du
fruit de notre travail et arrêter de
penser à comment on va reverser de
l'argent comment on va contribuer
comment on va apporter des aides arrêtez
de nous en prendre et vous savez nous on
sait gérer nos budgets donc vous dites
faouzi que lesdits clavier est plus
difficile à vivre aujourd'hui qu'il ya
trois ans mais comment vous expliquer
qu'à l'époque il y avait des centaines
de milliers de personnes dans les rues
et qu'aujourd'hui et bien bon ben ça se
comptent par centaines par milliers au
maximum alors ya trois ans on a décidé
de prendre nos responsabilités de sortir
dans la rue on a dit stop à ce système
qui dure depuis déjà trop longtemps
aussi bien des représentants politiques
qui prennent des décisions pour nous il
adapté aussi bien de la liberté de la
pratique des prix qui fait que c'est
toujours nous qui payons et à un moment
donné on veut être considéré vivre avec
le four in de travail aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya moins de monde mais
la faute à qui pendant trois ans n'a pas
subi une répression n'y a pas eu des
condamnations des gens blessés sans en
dissuade quelques-uns mais sachez
aujourd'hui les citoyens que si demain
vous ne bougez pas c'est pas ce
gouvernement qui va bouger pour vous
demain pour changer les choses ça
passera que par vous parce que là ça
l'opposition elle est citoyenne
aujourd'hui y a personne aujourd'hui qui
est capable d'apporter de représenter
les citoyens meilleur que les citoyens
parce que les politiques ils pensent
qu'à leur carrière ils pensent qu'à eux
et ils ont que des ambitions financières
et politiques et nous on essaye de
représenter la population nous moi je
fais pas partie d'un groupe politique je
fais pas partie d'un parti je fais pas
partie d'un collectif je suis un simple
citoyen un simple citoyen engagé au même
titre que les autres les choses elles
peuvent évoluer changer que par les
citoyens c'est aux gens à se mobiliser
pour dire non on exige aujourd'hui que
les choses aillent change et ça changera
que par nous-mêmes c'est pas eux qui
vont nous le donne et si on va pas le
chercher donc on arrête de demandez pas
ce que demande et on l'a fait ils savent
très bien ce qu'on a besoin et savent
très bien nos sollicitude ne nos
revendications mais ils veulent pas nous
les donner donc ils font fi d'un bilan
qui est positif il est complètement
négatif on a régressé dans nos acquis
sociaux et dans la démocratie est
aujourd'hui ça nous coûte très cher dans
notre quotidien dans notre vie sociale
merci merci pour ce témoignage faouzi
lellouche alors vous l'avez entendu un
la colère de ce gilet jaune emblématique
et bien qui ne faiblit pas un trois ans
après la naissance du mouvement il est
plus qu'urgent ans d'après faouzi bien
de se mobiliser il a appelé le plus
grand nombre à rejoindre ce mouvement et
des gilets jaunes un mouvement qui est
et bien peut-être va
reprendre pour une saison 2 c'est en
tout cas la volonté de très nombreux
chez les jeunes une saison 2 avant six
mois avant les élections présidentielles
voilà qui est bien pourrait embêter le
gouvernement voilà ce que l'on peut dire
sur cette manifestation actuelle où le
cortège devrait partir de la place de la
bastille d'ici une demi-heure à peu près